[Music]
since i visited the border a couple of
weeks ago
a lot has happened tens of thousands
more
illegals and unaccompanied minors have
entered the country
border patrol is even more inundated
than they were two weeks ago
we are finding more and more that when
the rare group of individuals
are being tested they have a 10 percent
coven positive rate no surprise
given the pictures we see of immigrants
literally within inches of each other
traveling in large groups through many
countries
are now actually being sent into the
interior of the united states
to a town or village near you
shockingly as they move through the
interior we hear of
teachers now the same ones refusing to
teach
our children volunteering to teach these
immigrant children
through july an issue i'll address in my
closing statement
it appears the biden administration's
theme of america
last is in full force the work of the
cartels and the coyotes continues
as they inhumanely traffic children and
young girls
in the dangerous trek from the northern
triangle
this week in a testament to their
brutality
we saw coyotes literally throw two
little girls
ages 3 and 5 over the 14-foot
border fence from mexico into the middle
of new mexico in the united states
in the desert miles from the nearest
residence
it is a video of smugglers abandoning
little girls
and leaving them for whatever natural or
human predators
that might find them fortunately
border patrol again has come to the aid
of those victims
as this crisis explodes on our southern
border the amazing part
has been president biden's refusal to
even visit the reason
the region to see how his policies have
damaged
and continued to damage our nation and
in a move that is
almost humorous he's essentially handed
off responsibility for this crisis
to his vice president kamala harris who
seems to see
humor in everything for her part
miss harris has refused to answer any
questions about the border
in fact when asked if she would even
visit the border
this was her response
do you plan to visit the border
not today
but i have before and i'm sure i will
again
as an aside why does that woman always
laugh
when she's asked serious questions how
crazy is it that joe biden would appoint
his vice president kamala harris
to solve the border crisis when she
compared ice agents
an essential law enforcement agency to
the ku klux klan
a little white house intrigue here a
senior aide for kamala told reporters
that the vice president would not be
doing the border
and instead she would be tackling the
policy issues
focusing on the root causes of illegal
immigration
essentially removing her from any blame
for the disaster at the border
but we don't need her to had an
investigation a commission or a study
in order to determine the root cause of
this surge in illegals
crossing our border the root cause is
clear
and it is the biden harris
administration and their reckless
policies
on january 20th they swung america's
doors open to any and all
who wanted to enter into the united
states and they haven't stopped coming
through those doors
the invitation was clear even mexican
president obrador has referred to joe
biden
as the quote migrant president he places
blame
solely on the shoulders of joe biden
especially
since joe canceled the mpp remain in
mexico policy
agreed upon by president trump and the
mexican president
not only is this a public health crisis
because of the administration's
inability or refusal to test migrants
for coven
before shipping them all over the
country
not only is this a humanitarian crisis
because of the administration's decision
to place children in horrifying
unacceptable inhumane
and barbaric conditions and those are
alexandria ocasio-cortez words
this is a national security crisis
we are a sovereign nation and yet we
have no idea
who's coming into this country sheriff
denels told me individuals from more
than
141 countries have entered the u.s along
his sector
the hundreds of thousands crossing are
not just from the northern triangle of
el salvador honduras and guala guatemala
they're coming from turkey and iran
and yemen and 138 other countries
take a listen to congressman mccarthy
the units of people who are coming from
different countries from iran from yemen
from sri lanka from turkey that is
different than it was before
90 percent of the heroin coming into
this country i said
90 percent comes in through our southern
border
fentanyl is coming in in amounts large
enough
to take down an american city so that's
just a recap
of the two weeks since i've been at the
border every week the nightmare becomes
greater
and bigger and more dire stay tuned
everyone
it's only going to get worse
and that's my open let me know what you
think on my facebook and twitter
hashtag judge janine